so how are you Jesse is that a loaded
question change since the last time we
saw each other just business as usual
but Beyonce moment when viral which was
pretty incredible but what was so
amazing is your photo with them the
first time was simple you had them on
your chest and people loved it I mean I
posted a photo of myself pregnant in my
underpants and I expected like a couple
thousand people would see it millions of
people saw that vote that I didn't
expect and then the photo with the
babies we took they were born five weeks
early so we were in the hospital in the
NICU and we took that picture and my
husband took that picture in the NICU
and so many people said to me like when
did you get your hair done when did you
go to we took it in the hospital days
after they were born I found out I had
twins it was such a shock and it was not
what I had envisioned or wanted and then
the moment we found out that there was a
possibility of losing one that's when I
said oh no no no we're having two no
matter what it takes what Jesse's
beautiful pictures of our family may not
tell our the very scary days of her
pregnancy
Jesse opened up in a blog post with
Flair magazine that she was carrying
rare monochorionic identical twins and
they developed twin to twin transfusion
syndrome meaning that one twin was
getting less of the blood supply and
nutrients it needed while the other was
being overloaded 80% of babies don't
survive luckily Rio and Diego did that
time must have been very difficult for
you you're gonna make me cry
right away and that's just the story of
my life yeah it's true these are little
miracle babies they're identical twins
we had a really scary high-risk
pregnancy and I had to get a laser
surgery to save them and it worked and
they're both here and they're both
healthy and gorgeous and hilarious and I
feel so lucky do you love being a mom I
do it's
it's the coolest thing in the world like
oh I just had my makeup done I'm gonna
start crying through it's really amazing
you know I've been very lucky and we've
known each other for a long time and
like in my career I've done some really
cool things I've produced really amazing
things but I've never produced anything
as a meeting as them and it's uh it's
the thing I'm most proud of